el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro consigue Que 20 países que
con sus delegaciones internacionales han
acudido a esta cita suscriban lo que fue
su lema para convocar la Cumbre más
democracia cero sanciones de esta forma
presiona ponen la agenda política la
necesidad y esa exhortación que ha dicho
textualmente en otras ocasiones Gustavo
Petro de que el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro y la oposición la plataforma
unitaria vuelvan a la mesa de
negociación de México estancada desde
noviembre Cabe destacar que ahora
empezará un tira ya floja para ver quién
da el brazo a torcer antes si el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro o la
comunidad internacional la comunidad
internacional le pide al presidente
maduro y a su gobierno que convoquen una
cita electoral en 2024 a la que puedan
asistir observadores electorales
europeos también que levanten las
inhabilitaciones a cargos políticos y
que liberen presos políticos el gobierno
de Nicolás maduro por su parte lo que ha
estado pidiendo es que se liberen los
fondos congelados internacionalmente y
que se también se levanten las sanciones
sobre las sanciones el jefe de la
diplomacia josep borrell le ha dicho a
nuestros compañeros de Efe que está
dispuesto a levantar las sanciones
incluso personales